hey lebron i wanted to know what it was
like to go out there with
kobe surely on your guy's mind and heart
and um did you notice the moment
early on when you're up 24 to 8 in the
first quarter
um it was an honor it's been an honor to
just put on the laker uniform
even before the passing um of the great
kobe bryant
um tonight was another one of those
moments for myself for this organization
all the players that
was able to wear those uniforms that he
uh
that was inspired by him and his mind
and his creativity
um so to go out there and um
and and one day removed from his
birthday um and then his
his day of 8 24 to be able to have a
game on this day
um the stars aligned um i did notice uh
that we were up 24 to 8
because i'm always trying to figure out
what's going on throughout the course of
the game i'm always looking
if we're up if we're down what's the
team fouls and all of that nature and
when i looked up there and seen 24 to 8
i was like okay
this is um he's here in the building so
um
you know it was a beautiful beautiful
night for our franchise
um and it's something that that we
probably will always
remember um you know game four of the
2020 playoffs
in this moment
hey lebron just thinking about today and
being mom a day
what does the mava mentality mean to you
specifically
and how do you think part of that might
have played out just work hard
i mean it's not much more you could say
everyone has their own
definition about it or or they all
mantra about it
but you don't get better you don't you
don't see any benefits if you don't work
and uh
i've always been like that um and
to be able to continue his legacy is
something that that hits home for me and
it's easy for me because
i put in the work and uh and if you want
to see results you gotta you gotta you
gotta work at it
and it's not about the wins and the
losses and and
you know all of that nature is just
about a lot of people want to see
results but a lot of people don't want
to put into work
and uh and he wasn't one of those guys
and i'm not one of those guys so
just honored to be able to continue that
legacy
what was it about the offense not just
tonight but last night that has started
to fall into place of
lebron for the entire team and look the
three-point shots going down seems to be
part of that but
what is what has come together on that
end for you guys this quickly
i want to get better every game
we're seeing things that we can do
better uh the most important thing we've
done in this series is we've taken our
in between games uh film sessions
our meetings and uh we've applied them
to that next day
you know we look at film we watch film
we know it's not much practice time
you really can't really get on the floor
too much because you're playing every
other day
so you you know that that next day is
kind of the recovery day and things of
that nature but our minds are sharp and
our minds are
our firing we're in our film sessions
and that's been very that's been huge
for our ball club so far
allie joe garden
i forget what it is but your record
in close-out game is way up there
is it does it feel good one to be back
in the situation
close out games and what do you remember
about what it takes to
finish these off um it's the hardest
game of a series
that's what i know it's the hardest game
because you know the team that you're
playing with are desperate
and they're playing all you know
everything they don't have
you know they'll give you everything
that they got um because they know they
can be you know sent home
um you know so i come in with that same
mindset that same uh the same desperate
mindset
on um you know i feel the same way you
know we don't win
i feel like we get sent home and that's
just been always been my my motive
that's always been my
my my psyche my mindset going into a
close-out game and um
i haven't always haven't always been you
know victorious but i have that mindset
and
hopefully we can do just that on
wednesday
um george hill was asked today about
jacob lake in that situation he said
he was asked what can you do from
orlando he was asked what can you do
from orlando to help
he said we can't do anything we
shouldn't even come to this damn place
i wonder i know your thoughts on that
have been a little bit different i
wonder what your reaction to that is and
what do you think about that
um i don't have any reaction to george
hill's comment
everyone has their opinion so you know
in reaction to what happened
what i can say is that um
if you're sitting here telling me that
there was no way
to subdue
that gentleman um or or
detain him or to just
before the firing of guns
then you sit here and you lie it's not
only me
you lying to every african american
every black person
in the community because we see it over
and over and over there was
multiple if you watched the video there
was multiple
moments where if they wanted to they
could have they could attack with them
they could have grabbed them you know
they that they could have done that
and why why does it always have to get
to a point
where we see the guns fire
and his family is there the kids are
there it's
in a broad daylight
and um and who knows i mean if that
video
is not being taken by that person across
the street
do we even know if we even see that
video
there's like talks about that the cops
didn't have body cams on
that's a possibility um
it's just it's just uh
quite frankly it's just [ __ ] up in our
community
and i said i know people get tired of
hearing me say it but we are scared as
black people in america like men black
women
black kids we are we are terrified
because you don't know you have no idea
you have no idea how that cop
that day left the house you don't know
if he walking on the good side of the
bed you don't know if he won't
work on the wrong side of the bed you
don't know if he had an argument at home
with a significant other you know one of
his kids said something crazy to him and
he left the house steaming
all right maybe he just left the house
in and today is gonna be
the end for one of these black people
that's what it feels like that's what it
feels like
um
it just it hurts it hurts and it's this
through the grace of god that he's still
living like seven shots
close range and he's still alive
that's through the grace of god right
there and um my prayers goes out to that
family and that community
but i got nothing nice to say about
those cops at all
at all is it is it hard to play
basketball when you're feeling when you
see something like that and
you know you have this
fear and you know anger and all the
emotions that you're doing
um
i had so many emotions today because you
know today is for our organization is
a big moment for organization you know
today is kobe bryant day
we're supposed to be celebrating
rejoicing
and remembering everything he's ever
done not only on the floor but off the
floor of uplifting
uplifting the game of basketball and at
the same time
i see the video today for the first time
and my emotions
is all over the place and i still have a
job to do
because i'm here because i committed and
when i commit to something i feel like i
have to come through on it that's just
who i am
but it does not mean that i don't see
what's going on and i won't
say anything or continue to use my
platform to continue to use my voice and
continue to uplift
all the other athletes that let them
know that they can say and do
what's right and not fear what other
people's opinions are
um it's just it's it's
it's it's tough it is it's tough and
like we literally we want we want change
as a community
we really want change and
it doesn't not only just end in november
but it starts there
um it starts there and um
but we got to continue to still keep our
foot on the pedal then
even if we get what we want we still
have to we still need more
what what are we getting because right
now
of what's going on is not it's just not
okay
and um but i hope i can continue to
uplift my community uplift communities
all over america
uplift the black community um i said
that's part of reason why i started more
than a vote
to you know just to get people to
understand how important our voices
are and um luxury of
you know partnering with naacp today
trying to get
younger uh kids in there to help with
the with the poles and things of that
nature because of colvin and
the older generation are at risk and
it's just so much that we have to do
it's not like
it's going to happen tomorrow but being
organized and having a plan
and and um and keeping our foots
on the keeping our feet on the gas pedal
is um
something that we got to do i know i'm
kind of all over the place but
my emotions is all replaced as well it's
real i like
i can't even enjoy a playoff win right
now which is
which is which is which is the sad part
all right sorry we're gonna take a
couple more
um kyle um
sorry i know you're just an emotional
thing why don't you ask me today
you told us a couple weeks ago that you
know you've had this desire maybe to
be out there with some of the black
lives matter marches and things like
that obviously
here you have to take the behind closed
doors approach to a lot of these issues
um how do you kind of kind of balance
maybe your desire to have your hands on
the situation versus
um you know the need to kind of have
that organized plan
um i don't think i'm behind closed doors
because i can get up in it right now and
talk to you guys about what's going on
um anything that my name is attached to
is going to be
you know put out and we want to do
things that that hits home
and do things that's grand and not
something that's just one-off
um you know so
you know i'm having conversations
every day you know i got half of
you know my brain you know locked in on
the playoffs and others have locked in
on how the hell i can help
black people become greater in america
and um you know that's what it's all
about
anybody got another
this whole situation the importance of
voting
what expectations do you have what
reforms
about police
um
i don't want to sit here and say that i
know exactly what should be done
um but i did see i did see one
one thing about
the level of time in the academy before
you become a police officer
um i think it was like
i don't know i don't want to mess it up
but i know it wasn't that long
so you're going to academy you know and
then becoming a police officer
um i mean we got kids that's going to
college
three or four years you know it's six
years
you know to get uh
you know their masters you know their
things or they even have to you know go
again
um you know and and they still don't
even get the opportunity
at the workspace or the job that they
actually want to get
but we have people who are going into
the academy who's becoming police
officers in a year or two or
whatever you guys can look it up and
then tell me so i don't want to get it
wrong but
um and i think i think firearms are a
huge issue in america
i don't know how you clean that up i'm
not saying and saying that i got all the
answers but
guns are they are a huge issue
in america um and not just they're not
used for just hunting
you know that a lot of people do for
sport
you know we right now for black people
right now we are hunting we think it's
you hunting us
unfortunately there's just too many
killings going on
and not only from the cops but we also
have our own thing that we got to deal
with that we got to get better as well
the black on black crime we got to get
better at that as well
you know but what we continue to see
from from the people that are supposed
to serve and protect
you know when i when i was in elementary
and they used to come
uh you know to the elementary and they
used to talk about how they you know
great to give us t-shirts you know the
uh
if i was a crime dog used to come
to the dare to dare yeah
he's gonna give his t-shirts it was like
happy to see him
i even had a couple uh you know cops
that i you know
growing up that i was like happy to see
every now and then
um but you always had like in the back
of your head it was like
just got to be careful you always got to
stand on your toes because you just
don't know
you just don't know i've seen a video a
few months ago
was it a few months ago or maybe a
couple months ago a police officer
rolled past
and a kid was in his in his parking lot
shooting basket
shooting basketball y'all seen that one
yeah and when she was in the damn cop
was about to ride by the kill
walked behind his dad's truck and waited
for the cop to go by
that [ __ ] sad no kid should have to feel
that threat that he
has to hide at his own house
that is sad but i know what he's going
through because i was one of those kids
when i lived in the projects that when i
seen the cop going we look behind the
brick wall
and wait for it to roll out and if we
seen the cop lights come on we ran
even if we wasn't even if we didn't do
nothing wrong because we just
was just scared it's tough
yeah we can move the chair out of the
way
all right tanisha when you're ready
we're ready for you
hello hey anthony uh it's dave
can you uh just first tell me uh
how your your back's doing and then also
please reflect on the strong performance
you guys had on a night where obviously
you're wearing that jersey
right now um back is going fine
uh i'll be fine um but we came out very
dominant
um you know obviously we know they are
going to play with a sense of
desperation and we want to be their
playing team
we came out with that sense of urgency
that we need
both on both ends of florida um
you know we were able to you know
win this you know on a very emotional
special night for us winning kobe
jerseys and
realizing that the first time we you
know played again
after the tragedy
was also against portland they were able
to take that one from us at home but
you know we just wanted to make sure
that we did everything we could to get
this
hey anthony frank vogel mentioned the
plus 37
in your 17 minutes and just the what you
had going on both ends
was there anything specifically that you
thought helped you get to that level of
effectiveness uh maybe you know just the
kobe stuff going on what
what got you to that level tonight i've
just been aggressive
uh my whole thing is be aggressive for
her that's the time here
you know i don't want to come out and
and not be aggressive
you know the team needs to be aggressive
and i've been able to
you know find spots that i'm very
comfortable and
you know just take my time to make shots
so um but also making the right reason
guys i'm making shots so
you know we're making shots you know
from the perimeter
from inside the paint it opens the floor
for everyone then i just have to
you know take one time and you just
wonder what it's like playing with
lebron
in in this mode in the playoffs right if
you see a different level that you know
you had seen in the past watching him
in the postseason and how you two play
off each other
um obviously we kicked it up a notch
you know his his level of focus has
definitely
increased and the entire team level
focus increased increased
you know he he's very detailed about
everything he's in there with the
coaches for film sessions he's talking
to me
doing film sessions uh you know off the
court
or not you know more so talking about
basketball you know we talking about
anything
else you know watching might be watching
other games or playing video games or
whatever and he's
something just registers in his head and
he he just you know talks about it so
um you know he wants to win i want to
win and you know that it's going to take
both of us to do it in the entire team
um and so we're just trying to continue
to find ways to get better
even after you know when it's like this
there's always something that we can get
better at for game five and
you know i'm pretty sure that he's going
to have a list of things for me tomorrow
and for our team
and um so it's a culture that we try to
get better
tanya just talking to again
for a while about he brought he brought
up kind of the fear
that black people
and the fear that black people live with
when it comes to politics
and he described himself as a kid and
like having a high five
law office on a police car driving by or
run if they heard the sirens um i just
wondered from
your experience growing up in chicago
like what was your
what did you associate the police with
like what was your experience
um obviously growing up in the city um
you know
what brown said it's kind of the truth
um
you know i was you know fortunate to you
know
have everything i needed at home i had a
bachelor in my backyard
you know my parents both my parents were
there
both my parents worked at cars
you know were able to go to a school
outside of the inner city
um but you know i still live in the city
you know and i've seen things
you know and from from my perspective
um from both sides you know from police
and from um you know
the black side and it's just i don't
know it just has to
it just has to get better honestly um
you know but like ron said like growing
up you see things that kind of
make you afraid of the police for sure
and it kind of just stays with you as
you as you grow up in there obviously
there's the things that's
that's going on now and it happened
today with jacob blake
uh which is which is totally
unacceptable um
you know and we definitely want to use
our voices for that you know victim as
well
and you know he's one of the lucky ones
because he's surprised
and he's stable so um i'm pretty sure
he's going to have a lot to say about
him and his family but
um you know it kind of just carries with
you you know
for your real life and what you see the
current events that's going on
going on today it just make you go back
to your childhood and remember
you know why um you're afraid
and i don't have any you know teenage
boys but i know brian talked all the
time with but his two
kids you know um and
just a tough situation um the world is
scary right now
um you know the most we can do we use
our voices
uh you know ron talked about talk to us
about
you know voting all the time you know he
started you know his
his uh organization uh for everyone to
vote and
uh that's kind of where it starts for us
um kind of
continue to push the envelope on on
wanting change
and um you know we got we got to do our
part
and you know we know we're here
for basketball but that's not only our
main focus
may focus on social justice and
you know we are lucky to have you know a
ton of guys who
who are public figures
you know you know like brian you know cp
all these guys who
you know always on the forefront and
speaking out and
able to kind of guide the younger guys
um and to steer them in the right
direction and kind of follow their lead
so
you know we're fortunate as an
organization to have one on our team
um who loves to you know go out there
and
put his foot forward um and we kind of
just followed his own steps and
you know kind of kind of you know make
sure that we're doing the right thing as
well
anything anymore see if anything on your
end please
i do have two last questions david
a.d david aldridge man um just stand on
that
topic for for a minute how difficult is
it
as you continue to progress through the
playoffs
to kind of compartmentalize on the one
hand you're competing for a championship
and you have a team that could win one
but you also have the social justice
piece that's very important to everybody
and that everybody wants to keep front
of mind how much how difficult does it
become as you continue to progress
through the season and through these
playoffs
um i think you know while we're on the
floor you know our main focus to win the
bathroom
and when we're off the floor um you know
our main focus is to continue to like i
said push the envelope on social justice
and create a change and you know
our organization and our team are
constantly having talks
um on how to do that you know obviously
it's difficult
difficult for us to you know
for us not to be able to be out outside
this bubble
and help create change
um physically but we're doing the best
we can inside this bubble and
i think all our leaders that that's here
um
are helping in that manner and you know
we can't
lose sight of what's going on outside
outside the world even though we're
playing a game that we love and competed
for
you know a championship and um
but at the same time you know events
that you know happened today kind of put
everything into perspective that you
know
it is a basketball game but we still
have you know things going on outside
the bubble
that's real life and um the more we can
do to
to help bring attention and awareness to
those you know situations and
and the more we can help and use our
voices um
the better off we can be but um
you know we try to we try to keep
everything into perspective and when
we're not on the court
you know our minds are definitely trying
to figure out ways to help
last question andy
thanks everyone on zoom thanks tanisha
thank you